mais à messieurs bonsoir tous ses
passagers au sourire un peu pâle sont
bien sûr les ex otages du boeing de la
lufthansa pour eux tout s'est terminé
eh bien sans une seule victime aux
alentours de minuit la nuit dernière
quelques heures plus tard le monde
apprenait le suicide d'un drea ce
baladeur et de deux cerveaux de son
groupe infernal dans la prison de toute
carte où il était supposé être coupé
totalement de l'extérieur voilà donc
deux événements exceptionnels qui mérite
vous en conviendrez qu'on leur accorde
la plus grande partie de notre journal
mais devant l'ampleur des documents de
toutes les pièces que de cette journée
qui aura indéniablement constitué un
tournant dans l'action terroriste
international devant donc l'abondance
des images des faits des commentaires
nous allons vous présenter ce dossier en
deux parties la libération des otages et
la femme bad et nous allons essayer de
le faire avec le maximum de rigueur et
minimum de phrases première image 7 au
milieu de visages rayonnants la photo de
l'homme du jour
helmut schmidt qui venait accueillir son
collègue anglais james callaghan un
chansonnier je voyais et débordant de
bonheur encore capable de répondre aux
journalistes que s'il avait réussi à
tenir
depuis vendredi c'est parce qu'il buvait
beaucoup de coca cola
l'interlocuteur de ce chancelier
rayonnant sait de quoi il parle james
callaghan devait déjà venir en allemagne
il ya un mois mais sa visite avait été
annulée en raison d' enlèvement de
sljeme juge d'ailleurs dont on a
d'ailleurs toujours aucune nouvelle
nous y reviendrons plus longuement en
cours de journée mais revenons sur ces
images que nous vous montrions sur notre
générique l'arrivée à francfort de 80
étages du land souffle de la lufthansa
les six derniers étant restés à
mogadiscio légèrement blessés ou tout
simplement épuisé par ces quatre jours
d'une attente interminable
tout risque d'un drôle de voyage par 50
degrés de chaleur les traits tirés par
une attente de cinq jours dans l'univers
clos d'une carlingue de boeing affecté
par la mort de leur commandant de bord
les 80 otages du boeing 737 de la
lufthansa sont arrivés cet après midi à
l'aéroport de franz fla
quatre d'entre eux blessés alors que l'a
souhaité donner sont restés à mogadiscio
sur ces images
seuls les enfants semblent avoir déjà
oublié les 110 heures passées dans
l'avion
à 100 m de l'appareil sur l'aéroport de
francfort des barrières maintenait à
distance la foule qui n'a pu s'empêcher
d'applaudir la descente de l'équipage
l'afer est semble-t-il terminée mais
regardez bien ce jeune policier et sa
mitraillette
en effet jusqu'à cet après midi encore
au retour des otages libérés
les autorités allemandes craignent est
un dernier geste de désespoir de
terroristes encore en liberté
vous imaginez que tous ses passagers est
encore dans les yeux des conditions de
vie épouvantables à bord du boeing et
ils ont encore pour longtemps en mémoire
cette heure fatidique
la nuit dernière quelques minutes après
minuit la prise d'assaut par les
commandos spécialisées de l'armée
allemande de l'appareil de la lufthansa
deuxième image dont ils auront du mal à
se débarrasser l'assassinât du pilates
non non sans d'abord à haïr matin à
l'instant dramatique ou parle toboggans
d'évacuation les théories sont descendus
le corps du pilote
jochen schuemann qui le mort de cette
affaire froidement abattu devant les
passagers de l'avion otages assassiné
pour avoir semble-t-il refusé de
redécollé d'aden et puis tout de suite
0 heure 37 missions l'aéroport de
mogadiscio tout de suite après l'assaut
les 86 otages qui se trouvait enfermée
dans cet avion depuis jeudi dernier sont
rassemblés beaucoup n'ont pas encore
compris ce qui leur arrive n'ont pas
réalisé qu'ils sont à nouveau libres la
sonnaz brigade spéciale de la police
ouest allemande n'a duré en tout et pour
tout que cinq minutes
d'abord les portes de l'avion sont
arrachés un policier cris couchez-vous
des grenades aveuglantes explose les
quatre terroristes dont deux femmes sont
abattus une dizaine de passagers sont
légèrement blessés c'est ce que raconte
les premiers témoins
tout est fini ouais donc toutes ces
images datent de quelques minutes
quelques heures après l'assaut du boeing
alors je crois pour mieux comprendre
comment les choses se sont réellement
passé je vous poserai monteras à l'aide
d'une maquette de nous expliquer le
détail de cette opération
oui sur de nombreux modèles d'avions
mais pas sur tout chaud
d'ouvrir les portes de l'extérieur sans
qu'on soit obligé de les faire sauter
vous savez que la brigade antigang
allemande a fait sauter les portes de
l'appareil
vous le voyez sur cette maquette le
boeing 737 possède quatre portes deux à
l'avant deux à l'arrière quatre portes
automatiques d'accès normal de chaque
côté et il y a également au milieu d'eux
porte de secours qui permettent
l'évacuation en cas d'urgence en cas
d'atterrissage
or d'une piste normal d'aérodrome ou en
cas d'amerrissage qui permettent
l'évacuation des passagers par toboggan
en plastique que l'on déploie le long de
l'ale et qui permet de vous laver je
voulais dit
l'évacuation des passages bien donc à la
faveur de la nuit les 60 hommes du
commando gsg9 se répartissent le long du
boeing et un top précis les six portes
plastique et sautent en même temps les
hommes antigang allemands sont à
l'intérieur de l'avion
ils lancent des grenades aveuglantes que
sont les grenades aveuglantes et bien ce
sont des grenades offensives qui
possèdent des enveloppes de carton ou de
plastique et elle explose en faisant
énormément de bruit ce qui a déjà un
effet psychologique certain
et puis en explosant elles produisent
également une très grande lumière
blanche qui permet de voir l'adversaire
que vous avez en face de vous et surtout
elle explose sans produire des clashs
qui est capital et je crois savoir aussi
j'ai pris quelques renseignements à
paris que les policiers allemands ont
utilisé simultanément des espèces de
grenades à main des sortes de
vaporisateurs qui projette à quatre ou
cinq matchs sur l'adversaire sous forme
de gouttelettes un liquide paralysant
qui paralyse pendant 5 à 6 secondes
daniel bilalian vous l'a dit hop
d'assaut 00h05 après tout effet permis
l'opération sans bavure donc tout aussi
réussie que celle des israéliens sur
l'aéroport dante b une opération à
mettre au crédit d'un homme et d'une
organisation l'homme c'est hans jürgen
vichnievsky
l'envoyé spécial d'helmut schmidt dans
le golfe persique depuis en somalie
il a tout monté tout coordonner tout en
négociant l'organisation c'est un peu
l'équivalent de notre brigade antigang
une brigade d'élite créée il ya cinq ans
après l'épisode tragique des jeux
olympiques de munich un entraînement
rigoureux depuis 60 doses qui n'avaient
jusqu'alors jamais été mis à profit
l'assaut du boeing a présenté sa
première interview
l'homme d'abord hans jürgen vichnievsky
56 ans fils d'un mineur ancien ministre
de la coopération
sa connaissance des pays arabes lui a
valu le sobriquet de bennwihr il est
l'homme de confiance du chancelier
schmidt
il a coordonné toute la sphère et
préparer le terrain au plan diplomatique
à l'intervention du commando le commando
anti terroriste ensuite 60 garçons que
voici à leur retour à cologne la foule
les y accueille en héros
deux ou trois d'entre eux selon le
communiqué imprécis de la chancellerie
ont été blessées à mogadiscio
ils appartiennent aux commandos gsg9
groupe spécial de la garde frontière
antiterroriste qui compte 178 mantoue
tous volontaires choisis pour leurs
qualités militaires et physique et leur
sang-froid exceptionnel leur efficacité
vient de leur rapidité d'exécution il
dispose du matériel le plus sophistiqué
et sont entraînés à faire face à toutes
les situations d'urgence à toutes les
formes de combat
ils sont prêts à intervenir dans le
quart d'heure qui suit la réception
désordre créé après l'attentât
palestiniens de munich en 1972 contre
l'équipe israélienne des jeux olympiques
le groupe gsg9 n'avait jamais jusqu'ici
l'occasion de montrer sa valeur
l'opération de mogadiscio était sa
première mission qui constituent une
force paramilitaire sous le contrôle
direct du ministre de l'intérieur
l'allemagne de l'ouest a dépensé 10
millions de marks environ 22 millions de
francs pour la création de ce corps
d'élite
voilà tout est dit ou presque sur
l'échec des terroristes de mogadiscio
mais quelques heures plus tard ce devait
être la seconde mort du mouvement avec
des conséquences autrement plus graves
informés on ne sait comment les cerveaux
de la bande à baader incarcéré dans une
prison de haute surveillance à stuttgart
dans des cellules individuelles sans
possibilité de connexion allait se
donner la mort à l'aube en fait
quatre d'entre eux ont essayé de le
faire 3 ils sont parvenus
andreas baader le chef le fils de
famille good run and clean la fille de
pasteur et ian carr rast la jeune femme
en cependant et les deux hommes à l'aide
de calibre 7 65
là encore nouvelle question comment ont
ils bien pu réussir à se procurer ces
armes à feu peut-être s'agit-il d'un
ultime pied-de-nez à la démocratie
allemande en jouant sur le doute ce qui
aura pu s'emparer de quelques esprits
quant aux conditions de leur mort
seul rescapé de ce suicide collectif
cette jeune femme que vous voyez en ce
moment et on garde melun qui s'est
tailladé la gorge mais qui pourra être
sauvé
l'ailé gauche dite de sécurité de la
prison de stuttgart
camara m et donc inhabitée depuis 6h30
mais la prison garde encore ses secrets
sur les conditions du suicide de ce
matin c'est dans cette cellule
qu'andreas bader s'est donné la mort
et c'est d'ici qu'il a peut être pu
inviter trois de ses codétenus à le
suivre dans l'autodestruction
le mystère le plus total règne encore
sur la manière dont bader ce fils
révolté violent du 68 allemand a pu être
informés des événements extérieurs à sa
cellule et communiquer avec ses voisins
symbole allemand de la terreur bader
avait été arrêté en 72 après une
fusillade avec la police
boudreau naisseline sa compagne l'avait
rejoint peu après en prison comme bader
elle a été condamné à la détention à vie
avec un cadre aspect bader et jan steen
former le noyau dur du terrorisme
allemand un constat la mort de ces
activistes violents est accueilli en
allemagne avec soulagement
je m'en suis réjouis nous dit-on ici je
ne crois pas à leur mort se sont
suicidés
c'est nouveau alors j'avoue que j'en
suis soulagé les carreaux rist mort
allongé une liste où figure le nom de
our minds qui s'est laissée mourir après
une grève de la faim
vader and clean et race peut on en fait
limitée ulrike meinhof qui s'est déjà
suicidé en 76
il serait cependant illusoire de croire
que le terrorisme est désormais vaincu
en allemagne fédérale
outre les 150 e terroristes emprisonnés
il reste un peu partout dans des villes
comme berlin par exemple des disciples
potentiels qui sont prêts à devenir
actif avec nous maintenant michel meyer
direct de bonnes pour essayer de
répondre à toute une série de questions
que nous posons tous d'abord première
question à michel meyer est ce que c'est
vraiment bien la fin de la bande à bâle
pour le moment c'est la fin de bader et
de quelques-uns de ses codétenus mais on
peut penser que
les disciples de bader vont utiliser son
nom comme celui d'un martyr et ils vont
éventuellement n'honorer ce martyr en
relançant des opérations de terreur peut
être encore plus nihiliste
cela dit ce que craint surtout le
gouvernement allemand et les allemands
d'une façon générale ce sont des
allusions qui tendrait à prouver que le
suicide de bader n'est pas effectivement
un suicide à titre prophylactique si
l'on peut dire
le gouvernement allemand a donc invité
des experts internationaux pour faire
une autopsie du corps d'andreas baader
et de ses co détenus qui se sont
suicidés avec lui
cette autopsie aura lieu dans le courant
de la soirée j'aime question ans michel
meyer maintenant le deuxième personnage
de la sphère helmut schmidt on a
vraiment l'impression qu'ils se sort
grandi de l'épreuve le chancelier est
effectivement grandi de cette épreuve il
suscite à l'heure actuelle l'admiration
de la plupart de ses concitoyens même
ceux qui votent généralement pour son
opposition
on peut dire que el mout schmidt dans
cette affaire s'est confirmée comme le
manager de crise qu'il essaie d'être
avec un certain succès il faut le dire
depuis son arrivée au pouvoir
politiquement on peut donc considérer
helmut schmidt comme tout à fait
indéboulonnable à l'heure actuelle en
allemagne et troisième personnage
maintenant de cette affaire on en a pas
parlé beaucoup aujourd'hui c'est le
grand oublié c'est hans martin schleyer
est-ce que vous avez des détails sur ce
sur le sort du prisonnier patronat
royalement la pression que j'ai et que
reims martine flyers a été
définitivement sacrifier à la raison
d'état
peu de gens ici se font encore des
illusions sur la possibilité qu'on en
aurait dans les prochains jours de le
revoir vivant
il est vrai que après les tensions une
nuit des dernières heures et de la nuit
dernière après l'annoncé du suicide de
d'andreas baader et de ses codétenus la
sphère schleyer l'enlèvement de reims
martine flyers qui a lieu il y a six
semaines maintenant est devenu un titre
assez tiède dans l'actualité et je crois
que l'on peut dire que son épouse et ses
fils doivent se sentir ce soir à
stuttgart à ses seuls dans le tourbillon
de cette actualité
il faut quand même dire michel qu' il y
à une heure le président de la
république allemande val tâche elle
lançait un appel aux ravisseurs de
monsieur flyers pour qu'ils libèrent
leurs otages finissons-en avec le cercle
infernal de l'âme
or et de la violence a dit le président
allemand l'autre grand oublié toutes ses
affaires et bien c'est aussi le
commandant du boeing hunt schuman qui
selon tous les témoignages a fait preuve
d'un courage exemplaire puisqu'il avait
réussi à communiquer à la tour de
contrôle de dubaï perd enseignements de
la plus haute importance sur une hôtesse
du 737 ils auraient été abattus après
d'avoir tenté de quitter l'avion et
c'est en mémoire de ce jeune pilote tuée
sous les yeux de son ami d'enfance le co
pilote que les organisations
internationales de pilotes ont un moment
envisagé une grève mondial de deux jours
à partir du 25 octobre
mais en fait on semble maintenant
s'orienter vers une manifestation
internationale devant le siège de l'onu
les pilotes sont plus que sensibiliser à
cette affaire de prise d'otage et déjà
certaines compagnies le rap n comment
réagit nous sommes dans certaines
compagnies formés pour que nous sachions
entretenir des relations et même des
liens quelquefois même affectif avec les
pirates où le pirate qui se trouve à
bord qu'est ce que vous entendez par là
nous pouvons au niveau d'un passage et
seul qui ce qui est peut-être un cas
touchés par une névrose ou une fille
cause récupérer la personne par un
contact humain affectif avec cette
personne c'est à dire que vous avez
suivi des cours de psychologie
nous sommes formés au travers de
projections de films diapositives pour
que nous sachions remédier à des états
de ce genre le commandant de bord de la
lufthansa a su accommoder la situation
interne a su comprendre ce que
représentaient les moyens armés de cépie
rap a su avertir c'est ce qui lui a
d'ailleurs coûté la vie mais il n'a fait
que son travail en fait car nous sommes
formés dans ce genre d'intention j'ai
pas besoin de vous dire que le monde
entier a condamné cette action des
terroristes
même si certains comme le mouvement
français lutte ouvrière en profite pour
rejeter en même temps ce qu'il appelle
la violence des appareils d'état
du côté français jacques chirac à helmut
schmidt françois mitterrand à villy
brent ont fait part de leur soulagement
devant ce dénouement heureux
valéry giscard d'estaing avait envoyé ce
matin un télégramme de félicitations au
chancelier ouest allemand
tout le mérite de la faire
le thé reviennent voilà toutes les
informations dont nous disposons ce
mardi 18 octobre sur la sphère du boeing
et sur ses suites
une journée qui indéniablement
constituera un tournant je crois qu'il
faut le répéter dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme une lutte jean françois kahn
qui remonte à beaucoup plus longtemps
qu'on imagine oui enfin on al'impression
fond ce que ce principe consiste à
enlever des otages à des fins politiques
c'était une sorte de machine infernale
qui à l'origine échapper à ses
inventeurs en effet faut bien le dire
c'est fidel castro qui a inventé ce
procédé
il a inventé dans les années 50 8 mai
pour faire parler de lui à l'époque
avait un dictateur à cuba et profitant
d'un d'une grande réunion de courses
automobiles les castriste ont eu l'idée
d'enlever fonds giot le grand champion
changions pour que tout le monde dise
mais qui sont ces gens qui ont fait le
coup
éduquons parler des castriste mais
l'idée n'était pas venue de l'échanger
contre quelqu'un mais naturellement très
rapidement on est passé un deuxième
stade enlever quelqu'un contre quelqu'un
un homme contre un homme et ses les
vénézuéliens les castris vénézuélien qui
ont eu l'idée
ils ont enlevé à jour un colonel
américain qui étaient en place à caracas
et ils ont voulu l'échanger contre un
viêt congs condamné à mort un homme
contre un troisième stade on y passe
insensiblement voyez toujours un stade
supérieur
un homme contre un groupe et ça c'est au
brésil c'est le révolutionnaire
marighella qui a eu l'idée d'enlever un
ambassadeur américain l'ambassadeur week
elle brigue c'était en septembre 69 pour
l'échanger contre un groupe de
prisonniers politiques
et cela a réussi jusqu'à présent il n'y
avait pas de victimes allemandes donnent
pas mort d'homme seulement à l'époque
j'avais j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer
la personne qui a exécuté le coût du
brésil cailloux font qu'à inventer si
vous voulez
l'esv m'en allais fins politiques et il
m'avait dit que lorsqu'il était face à
cet ambassadeur américain qui l'avait
enlevée il avait sympathisé tous les
deux finalement à force de rester
ensemble
il avait sympathisé lisa y discutait y
sentait assez proches l'un de l'autre
seulement il avait ajouté je savais que
je devais le tuer si le gouvernement
brésilien
ne cédez pas effectivement l'année
d'après c'est ce qui arrive ça se passe
là au guatemala ou enlèvement banalement
un allemand l'ambassadeur d'allemagne au
guatemala les autorités ne veulent pas
céder et on le retrouve mort tué d'une
balle dans la tente donc 4e stade un
homme contre un gros mais avec mort
d'homme alors à partir de ce moment là
la machine s'emballe et l'on passe à
l'idée d'enlever un groupe pour
l'échanger contre un gros c'est la prise
d'otages dans les avions massif ce sont
les japonais qui commence puis les
palestiniens et ensuite on a
l'impression que c'est de plus en plus
gros qu'eux
comment peut-on faire pour arrêter cette
machine infernale d'autant qu'aucun pays
n'était pas renié alors on essaye de
munich à munich à une tentative vous
savez que c'est un échec
donc on n'ose plus alors il y avait eu
naturellement de tb mais on on avait
l'impression que bon bah c'était parce
que c'était des israéliens et que seul
peut-être eux pouvaient ce qui est
nouveau je crois cette fois ci c'est que
maintenant
aucun gouvernement ne pourra se
permettre de céder maintenant devant la
menace des terroristes alors le problème
c'est de savoir que vont faire les
terroristes
d'autant que maintenant l'opinion
internationale les a complètement rejeté
et qu'aucun gouvernement de ce qui était
dit révolutionnaire n'a accepté de les
accueillir
voilà il est 20h21 le reste de
l'actualité assez brièvement je pense
que vous le comprendrez
d'abord le verdict au procès de prague
14 mois à trois ans de prison pour les
quatre intellectuels qui ont fait appel
et puis 30e anniversaire aujourd'hui du
conseil économique et social sous la
présidence de valéry giscard d'estaing
thème de son discours la croissance
économique
il s'est attaché à définir ce qu'il a
appelé une nouvelle économie n'est pas
une crise que nous vivons mais une
nouvelle étape at il dit un changement
du monde il faut d'abord répondre aux
deux interrogations fondamentales
s'agira-t-il d'une économie de
croissance
s'agira-t-il d'une économie ouverte
oui il devra s'agir encore d'une
économie en croissance
car la croissance des biens matériels
restent nécessaires pour assurer
l'emploi pour répondre à des besoins
légitimes encore non satisfaits dans
notre pays et pour maintenir notre place
dans le monde
l'évolution souhaitable de l'économie la
société française ne saurait désormais
se réduire à une simple croissance
quantitative
elle doit au contraire constituer un
développement à plusieurs dimensions
dont la croissance ne sera que l'un des
aspects c'est dire que moins encore que
par le passé cette évolution ne pourra
pas être résumée par un seul chiffre
si vous voulez me m'essayer au jeu
risqué du néologisme je dirais qu'il
s'agira d'une croissance quant aux
qualitative la deuxième question c'est
l'économie nouvelle sera t-elle une
économie ouverte où une économie isolé
questions essentielles dès lors qu'une
part importante de nos difficultés et
nous le savons bien nous vient de
l'extérieur
non la réponse à ces difficultés ne peut
résider ni dans des nids dans l'
isolement
ni dans le protectionnisme concorde
demain à new york mais ce n'est que pour
un vol d'essai après une très dure
bataille juridique il semble que
concorde et quand même gagné en
attendant le 22 novembre le premier vol
commercial est ce que pour autant cet
atterrissage résoudra tous les problèmes
posés par la décision
de la cour suprême d'abord n'oublions
pas que les riverains l'aéroport n'ont
pas dit leur dernier mot
voici une séance le hir et l'union c'est
à dire une séance de témoignages le
président de la séance est un citoyen
américain
un juré en quelque sorte chargé
simplement d'enregistrer les témoignages
avant de les transmettre aux autorités
de l'état chacun vient dire ici pourquoi
il est contre concorde ou pourquoi il
n'est pas franchement la passion n'était
pas absent du débat au moment de notre
visite
car tous les leaders de l'opposition à
concorde étaient présents à commencer
par carole barmes ne voulons pas de
concorde dit elle pour entendre ce genre
de bruit et nous continuerons la lutte
par des moyens légaux ou politique et
que ferez vous si concorde doit se poser
dans trois ou quatre jours
ici à new york et bien le gouverneur de
l'état de new york monsieur carrez devra
agir très rapidement il est le chef de
l'état et il a aussi la police avec je
veux vraiment dire que nous ne sommes
pas jaloux de concorde qu'on a pu
l'affirmer en france mais que bien au
contraire nous avons fait stopper la
construction de notre super sonic
américain car des personnes dans ce pays
ont pu faire entendre leur voix
oui il est maintenant que pouvez-vous
faire car concorde va se poser à kennedy
nous n'allons pas laisser l'aéroport
kennedy en paix car je vous affirme et
aussi longtemps que nous serons en vie
car olbermann moi et les autres
eh bien nous lutterons contre l'avion
supersonique
voici donc le dernier carré de
l'opposition à concorde
derrière eux 61% de la population
américaine selon un sondage récent et
surtout les habitants du coup les en
réalité seuls aujourd'hui le gouverneur
de l'état de new york
monsieur carrez peut s'opposer
la concorde par un veto
voyons maintenant le point de vue de
concorde dans cette histoire point
positif
maintenant que new york est ouvert bien
des choses peuvent se débloquer
atterrissage dans d'autres villes
américaines
miami dallas par exemple concorde s'est
déjà posée en 73 vous le voyez ici donc
des compagnies aériennes autre que air
france et british airways vont peut être
acheté ou au moins louer et cette
concorde restant l'abrasif américaine
iranair singapore airlines et odien
pourrait donc être intéressé des
destinations comme doc you l'australie
vont peut-être devenir des aéroports
supersonique
point négatif malgré l'atterrissage à
new york concorde n'est pas encore
rentable
air france ans utilisé l'avion 2200
heures par an avec deux vols par jour
sur plan de new york
mais la rentabilité et de 2750 heures
par an
concorde va donc continuer à perdre de
l'argent payé par le contribuable
français pour que vos la mc2 quelques
hommes d'affaires pressés alors en
juillet ce sont 18 la chaîne va
s'arrêter peut-être pour toujours
sûrement pour longtemps pour que cette
formidable expérience franco anglaise
est une suite un heureux dénouement
il faudrait à super concorde silencieux
robuste performant pas trop cher à faire
voler ce super concorde doit être
international euro-américain au moins
c'est cela le véritable avenir
maintenant que new york est ouvert les
américains vont peut-être se remettre à
croire au transport supersonique
mais pour dans dix ans car il reste bien
des progrès à faire
vous venez d'entendre c'est bien georges
leclercq et paraît un peu enrhumé il a
peut-être pris concordia dernière
journée dès 4e assises du cnpf une idée
forte dans le discours de clôture de
françois ceyrac un plaidoyer pour le
libéralisme avec une demande concrète du
président du cnpf la libération des
cuves des prix pas écoutons françois
serrés
la france vient de passer par une
période d'épreuves particulièrement dur
elle n'en est pas définitivement sorti
mais je pense qu'elle ne peut en sortir
que si dans les mois qui viennent on
peut rassembler les énergies des
français sur une nouvelle vision de
l'avenir de notre pays et tout à l'heure
j'ai proclamé notre volonté de
participer à côté des autres à ce
travail national devait également
évoquer le dirigisme qui par le passé
avait vous dis à étrangler un certain
nombre de secteurs dans l'économie
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de dirigisme y
en a encore et j'aurais bien voulu
parler au passé
je dis simplement que dans ce grand
programme de ce grand projet national la
liberté devrait trouver toute sa place
sur quelles propositions s'est achevée
6,6 patronale de nous rassembler pour un
nouveau bond en avant un nouveau bond en
avant ça veut dire continuer et
développer nos efforts pour
l'amélioration des conditions de vie au
travail et cela veut dire à bord d un
dialogue ouvert avec notre environnement
et notamment les collectivités locales
de très belles images aquatique
maintenant c'est une première mondiale
l'opération janus 4 qui a permis à
quatre plongeurs français de descendre à
460 mètres de fond ça se passait en
méditerranée et les quatre plongeurs ont
travaillé en tout 109 minutes par 460
mètres de fond cela constitue je vous
rappelle un record mondial
et puis pour terminer une vraie bonne
nouvelle demain soir mercredi à 20h25 du
football en direct
eh oui nantes atlético de madrid
comptant pour le match aller du deuxième
tour de coupe d'europe de football
ainsi grâce à l'aide des téléspectateurs
qui nous ont soutenus lors des
précédentes négociations
grâce aussi à la compréhension des
parties prenantes et faut le dire aussi
à l'action de la presse et bien le
service des sports d'antenne 2 vous
attend demain soir à 20h25 en direct
donc nantes
atletico puis toujours en sport
l'arrivée au cap du voilier français
japy hier mais si les derniers de la 1re
étape de la course auto du monde la
météo pour terminer bien pas de grands
changements par rapport à hier demain le
temps sera beau sur la plupart des
régions seuls quelques nuages
subsisteront sur l'extrême nord-est
quelques pluies également sur les
pyrénées et sur le golfe du lion voilà
la dernière édition de notre journal 2
vers 23h35 présentée par patrick lecocq
après les dossiers d'écran faute à tous
une très très bonne soirée à tous
bonsoir